Ahora quiero hacer una serie de problemas
clásicos que normalmente aparecen en las
competencias y en algunas pruebas estandarizadas.
A primera vista, pueden intimidarnos, pero
después de observar este video, te darás
cuenta que solo es cuestión de saber observarlos
y no son difíciles.
Veamos primero éste.
"a" más "b" más "c" es igual a 7 y nos preguntan,
¿a qué es igual "5a" más "5b" más "5c"?
La primer reacción es, si nada más tengo
una sola ecuación con tres variables,
con "a", "b" y "c",
¿cómo voy a resolver para "5a", "5b" y "5c"?
Piensa un poco en esto, pero la idea central
aquí, es darse cuenta que "5a" más "5b"
más "5c", no es nada más que cinco veces
"a" más "b" más "c",
si distribuimos el 5 en "5a", "5b" y "5c", obtenemos "5a" más "5b" más "5c".
Otra forma de pensarlo, es que
estamos factorizando el 5.
Si lo factorizamos obtenemos 5 que multiplica
a "a" más "b" más "c",
y ahora, ¿cómo evaluamos esto?
Pues la primera ecuación nos da toda la información
que necesitamos, porque nos dijeron que "a"
más "b" más "c" es igual a 7...
"a" más "b" más "c" es igual a 7...
y esto entonces es lo mismo que poner 5 veces...
y creo que ahora lo empiezas a ver con claridad...
5 veces 7, lo cual se evalúa directamente.
Entonces 5 veces 7 es igual a 35.
Vamos a hacer otro de este tipo para que vayas
familiarizándote con la idea,
ahora nos dicen que "a" más "b" más "c" es igual a -1 y
tenemos dos variables adicionales,
"x" más "y" igual a 7.
Y ahora nos preguntan por esta ecuación espeluznante...
Te voy a dar unos segundos para que pienses en esto.
Bueno, lo que se puede observar, es que en
la primera ecuación tenemos 3 variables y
luego tenemos una segunda ecuación con dos
variables, en total tenemos 5 variables
con 2 ecuaciones y no se ve forma
de cómo resolver esto.
Es decir, va a estar muy complicado ver de manera individual el valor de "a" o "b" o "c" o "x" o "y".
Utilizando la experiencia previa, vamos a
ver si podemos reagrupar esto de otra manera,
vamos a hacerlo.
Voy a observar primero, de manera alfabética
las "a", entonces tengo "-9a", luego voy con
la "b", tengo "-9b" y luego "-9c", creo que
empiezas a ver hacia donde voy.
Ahora vamos con las "x" y las "y" y tengo "-7x"
y aquí tengo "-7y"...
aquí con verde ser ve las "x" y las "y"...
Todo lo que he hecho fue reescribir esta expresión
y ahora observemos esta primera parte y parece
que hace sentido, escrito de esta manera podemos
observar qué es lo que está ocurriendo,
observo que en estos términos con "a", "b"
y "c" puedo factorizar el -9
y obtengo -9 que multiplica a "a" más "b" más "c".
Y estos dos términos de acá, puedo factorizar
el -7 y queda -7 que multiplica a "x" más "y",
si quisieras verificarlo solo es cuestión
de distribuir y llegarás a la expresión anterior.
Multiplica -9 por "a" más "b" más "c" distribuyendo
y obtienes lo que está aquí
y ahora podemos ver con claridad,
¿qué es "a" más "b" más "c"?
Pues aquí arriba nos dice que "a" más "b"
más "c" es igual a -1,
así que todo lo que está aquí, esta expresión en el paréntesis es igual a -1
y "x" más "y", ¿a qué es igual?
Pues nos lo están diciendo aquí, "x" más
"y" es igual a 7,
lo vamos a poner con su color.
Así que todo esto se simplifica a -9 veces -1...
sí, -9 veces -1 menos 7 veces 7...
menos 7 veces 7.
Y si evaluamos -9 por -1, nos da 9 positivo
y -7 por 7 nos da -49.
Y entonces, 9 menos 49 es igual a -40.